anthony grant's home is the university
of dayton they went 29-2 they would have
been a number one seed and
who knows what could have been coach
first of all congratulations
um how do you feel today dan thanks for
having me on i'm doing well man
i i appreciate uh your kind words and uh
obviously we're all going through you
know uh unprecedented time with with
everything going on in our country but
for the most part my family and i are
doing well
can you get over this as far as the
season and not being able to play in the
tournament
can you move on from it yeah yeah dan i
think the thing for me obviously you're
disappointed
for the players for your staff for uh
obviously
flyer nation but the big picture uh
of people's health and safety and you
know we can see what's going on across
the country right now when you take that
into account
uh yeah i'm grateful for what we were
able to accomplish and i'm also grateful
that
uh the decision makers saw said that
the health and safety of the general
public was more important
uh than proceeding with the tournament
and i respect that and
and so we choose to be grateful for what
we did get a chance to do over the
course of 31 games
if if the tournament was played
how do you think you guys would who was
your biggest competition
you know i i'm i'm not one that i look
ahead you know so obviously
the only team that that we played uh
you know that that was probably a lock
or two teams colorado and kansas you
know we felt like we fared well
we felt like we had a chance uh i didn't
get a chance to see a whole lot of other
people in our conference you know
obviously richmond
rhode island uh there were there were
several teams i thought that were worthy
to get in the tournament but
it's hard for me to compare other teams
across the country because i just you
know i kind of lock into us
and i don't really pay attention to
what's going on outside of scores
how was that uh conversation you had
with your kids when you told him that
there was no tournament
it was difficult you know we we uh we're
in brooklyn
for our tournament for the a-10
tournament and and uh we were scheduled
to play the winner of vcu
uh in umass and uh i was headed to to
watch that game
when the news came out that our
tournament was canceled so
i had to to quickly get the team
together back in our hotel and break the
news to them and
it was difficult especially when you had
to look in the eyes of you know trey
landers and ryan mike's of our two
seniors
knowing that you know this was this was
their last opportunity to
to compete for an 8-10 tournament
championship and what that meant
and you know we we also realized that
the dominoes could fall and
impact the the ncaa tournament so we
were hopeful that
maybe that there would be a postponement
rather than a cancellation
and then once we once we got on the
plane to head
back to dayton later that afternoon the
word came out
uh that the ncaa tournament had been
canceled so
it was kind of a you know surreal moment
it was
very quiet playing right back and trying
to gather my thoughts and met with the
team after and
a lot of emotion you know because they
realized that was it you know that they
wouldn't get a chance to play with each
other anymore and
you know that's difficult when it's not
in your control you know you can
you can probably deal with you know a
loss
had you had a chance to go out there and
compete and on a given night a team had
been
just better than you on that given night
uh but to not get a chance to compete
and have it in that way uh you know that
that's really difficult but
we got a group of guys that you know
they they uh
they really supported each other all
year and continue to support each other
i think as we kind of
go through what the rest of the country
is dealing with
and when we're all dealing with uh you
know with the uh the covet 19
that's uh that's still currently going
on i think you realize
in the big picture of things uh what
happened had to be done
he's anthony grant he's the head coach
of the dayton flyers
so you were on the flyers team that went
to the elite eight
yeah yeah 85 roosevelt chapman cedric
tony
damon goodwin ed young that crew yeah i
was a freshman
on that on that crew in 85. roosevelt
i try to explain to people about
roosevelt chapman who was i guess
6'4 but i saw him go against randy
brewer
who was 7-3 and either yeah and
and roosevelt chapman was one of those
guys that he couldn't shoot
but he could score against anybody yeah
you know it feels like that you know
every 10 years or so dayton has one of
those teams that people go boy
dayton yeah they made it to the elite
eight or this you know sweet 16 or
whatever it is
and i remember that was a pretty magical
run that you guys had
and uh roosevelt chapman was a pretty
impressive guy
yeah he was the darling of the ncaa
tournament that year you know we uh
we had some incredible wins lsu uh
washington oklahoma with layman tisdale
and then obviously
uh lost to uh georgetown in the in the
elite eight game
uh and they went on and won the national
championship that year but
you know roosevelt what he did over the
course of
uh uh the run of the ncaa tournament
i think was as good as any anybody's run
that i've ever seen
yeah it was pretty special and you also
were an assistant coach with the thunder
with billy donovan
and so you got kevin durant and russell
westbrook
do you remember the dr was there drama
though how much drama was there
when uh you know kd decided that he was
going to leave
you know there was really no drama you
know on on inside the building
you know obviously we we uh you know
made it to the western conference finals
and uh you know uh golden state uh ended
up
beating us uh in a seventh game and at
the end of the year
you know there was there was really you
know a wait-and-see approach to what
kevin's decision was going to be and i
think everybody in the building
respected the fact that he'd earned that
right to make a decision about what he
felt was best
for his future so once he made that
decision
you know we uh uh just kind of put our
trust in
in the front office to to move forward
and i i think they did a great job with
that and obviously the following year
uh russell westbrook became the mvp of
the league and you know
made history himself and and so uh you
know my two years there were a great
experience and
got a chance to be around some some
extremely talented and
and uh just just really great people
from
players to coaches and uh the management
team uh it was it was a great experience
who was easier to coach durant or
westbrook
well they're both great players you know
so so i
i think you you know you talk about
their their uh
their talents and their just their their
ability to
make everybody around them better you
know i i i enjoyed
you know being around both of them
handicapped ob
topping do you think is there a better
player in college basketball than ob
yeah i mean i i don't again you know i
haven't seen everybody there's a lot of
really great
great players out there but i think no
one can take away
what obi did from the start to the
finish you know for our team
we felt like you know we had a chance to
be
to be special when the season started
but i think when you look at
you know we were we were picked to
finish third in our conference and
nobody had us you know one of those
teams that were being talked about as
one of the top
30 40 teams in the country you know and
uh
obviously what obi did but what the rest
of our guys did over the course of the
season
just in terms of their buy-in their
willingness to support each other
sacrifice for each other
and uh you know hobie really separated
himself from
the beginning of the season all the way
through and i thought his consistency
his ability to stay focused when a lot
of
outside voices started realizing how
good he was
he was able to remain humble and to keep
his team
uh in the forefront of what we were
trying to do and i think it worked out
great for everybody
yeah pretty special season for him and
do you think you know
last question here really it's not a
question i mean
really i think it's obvious but uh the
chances of getting my jersey
in the rafters at the ud arena yeah you
know we had a meeting
uh yesterday a matter of fact neil
sullivan and i we talked about that and
yeah and uh i think the uh the consensus
is
probably not going to happen then okay
you can name the court after me i mean
there's a lot of other things there
coach
uh there's a parking there's a parking
spot with uh
that's got an available space that'd be
nice
parking spot would you would you be okay
with that how about i sponsor the
three-point line
so how would that work would your name
be on this point line oh yeah
yeah because i i didn't go inside that
now if you want to
how about this how about the dan patrick
bench area
because i never left the bench so could
you do that
that we can talk about how about a chair
coach can you talk about that
somebody sits in the dan patrick chair
on the bench
so is that is that the guy that turns it
over three times a minute no no he
didn't even get in he doesn't even get
in
he's great in warm-ups he's great in
warm-ups unbelief i used to keep track
of my points in warm-ups
that's sad coach yeah you got some great
ideas all right all right we'll work on
that
thank you coach you know that you are
one of the greatest flyers of all time
thank you coach
thank you and congratulations on a great
year thanks for having me on i
appreciate it anthony graham
dayton flyers head coach